.
T HAPPENED JUSA
HOURS AGO AND ISEADY AI AM RELI,
HIS IDEA WAS TO PUT RD OSUE. TP.
BU EFFOR
OOKER RESPONDE
CELEBRATING THE AMENDM
>> I CALL ON MCO
SUPPORT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT  VO.
GENTL'S
ADIDT. FROM NEW JERSEY.
>> IITISL AND
THISS .NIGHT.
IF ION
URES AND EWOULD WALKERE ANG AG .
WI
THAND E S SOMEOP
GIHAON L WE C PBETH TIVE T TOE T
TION, SOMEBODY, IN THIS
GREAT  BODY NT POLICE.
F US100 PEOPLK SASHA THERE VOTER
T  REST THE LIES THAT
ATTACKHERE OVE
DEFUND THEOLD I WOULD ASUNCO
SENATO THE ALSO THAT EVE
POLICE, LIGOD, COUNTRYPLPIE.ANK
>> S SOD.
THTE
>> I'M NOT SE THAT CORY IMPE HIF
MAYBE THAT'S WHY TOMMYVETHAT.
TUBBERVILLE WASN'T MOR
T AUBURN.
>> HE RE
HAD OFIC.VERY SENATOR BOTH
DEMOCRATS AN
VOOR
OF THE AMENDMENT. DID THEDO>> N